uh just so great to see sofcon uh
developing now to what it is I'm looking
I was just chatting with Sam who was one
of our first uh Special Operations
students here as a late career Yale
College student and helped found this
Special Operations conference at Yale in
2016 and since then uh under the
leadership of uh of Emma Skye and the
support of uh of Mr Kaplan you know
we've developed uh this PRK fellows
program at the Jackson school for Global
Affairs at Yale which is really you know
helped bring the Special Operations
Community into contact with the
outstanding resources that we have here
on the Yale campus and its teaching and
research Mission but I actually think
it's just as beneficial if not more for
the students who are not in that
community and so to be able to learn and
interact with all of you on the daily
basis you know the work that Mike and
his colleagues have done in putting this
conference together it's inspiration
National for our students it helps
enhance the public service mission of
what we're trying to do at Yale and it's
been Central to this effort to build
this Jackson School of global Affairs at
Yale so it's the first new school that
Yale has created in nearly 50 years
since our business school and reflects a
real commitment to putting challenges
and diplomacy and International Security
you know front and center at the mission
of the university in really exciting
ways I'm Ted Witten I teach at the
Jackson school and at the law school and
I oversee our International Security
studies program here at the Jackson
School which includes what we now call
the Schmidt program on artificial
intelligence emerging Technologies and
National Empower and so thanks to Dr
Schmidt he has really helped resource
our teaching and learning and
interdisciplinary approach to thinking
about how AI is changing the nature of
world order I see a number of students
who are in uh through the classes that
me and other colleagues teach at Yale in
this space and it's hard because it's
such a rapidly changing field and it's
hard to predict even what another six
months of chat gptx or something will
bring as the number continues to change
and so part of what we're trying to do
is create
a greater technical fluency among our
non-stem students so how do we develop
that among our aspiring lawn policy
leaders and then reverse because we have
so many stem students in our own courses
and connected to us around the elk
campus how do we develop that hybrid law
policy ethical appreciation for their
research agenda how do we integrate that
and maybe create a model for a best
practice that might extend as we think
about pipeline challenges and public
service and some of the comments that Mr
Ennis was just making so we have an
outstanding technology panel to continue
the conversation uh really terrific
expertise uh both in the science uh and
Technology of AI and Quantum Computing
I'll introduce Dr Krishnan and Dr girvin
in just a moment and then we have some
outstanding uh private sector expertise
as well that I'm eager to incorporate uh
and I'll introduce Mike Hayes in San
Jose as we go but we'll try to keep this
interactive
um and fun so Dr Krishnan is the w w
Cooper uh Ruth Cooper professor of
management science and information
systems at Carnegie Mellon University
and he's dean of the Heinz College of
information systems and public policy at
the University since 2009 he's been a
faculty member as well in engineering
and public policy really embodies this
connection of hybrid Tech and policy
fluency that we need to Grapple with AI
and the risks and opportunities he's a
member of the national AI advisory
committee as many of you know this is a
national level effort to try to harness
best practices uh from Academia to
inform uh government thinking so I
wanted to start with some comments from
Dr Krishnan on how he thinks about AI
both the risks and opportunities and
particularly its relevance to this
audience uh I was struck I like Mr
ennis's comments about uh being wary of
people who try to sprinkle AI dust on
everything and you've given a lot of
thought Dr Krishnan to what it really
means to develop a full AI stack really
the significant components both from
Hardware all the way through data and
algorithms to integration to human
people and so just give us a sense of
how you think about and scope this
challenge what concerns you most about
the current environment but also what
are some of the opportunities that you
think might be of of relevance to this
audience thank you
um thank you very much thank you Ted
um pardon the hostness my voice I'm sort
of seem to have allergies uh so um to
thank you again for the invitation to be
here to Ash and ashraja Rahman and to
Mike uh to invite me to come here uh
it's been a great learning experience
listening to speakers this morning
um and um established uh talking about
what Yale has put together here uh with
a Special Operations Command we have a
similar relationship at Carnegie Mellon
with the US Army there's an army AI
Center at Carnegie Mellon the Army
Futures command sends
officers for education at Carnegie
Mellon in Ai and we also
address senior leadership one Stars two
stars on data driven leadership and I
can speak to that as an important aspect
to the human capital aspects associate
it with the discussion that you've been
that we've been having
so Ted talked about the AI stack the AI
stack is something that um Carnegie
Mellon developed to organize
and frame the discussion about the
different components of AI technology
that are relevant to how it's going to
be deployed beat commercially be it and
government be it and in in to address
the kinds of questions that we are
hearing about today and it ranges and it
in some ways for those of you are very
familiar with the
UDA or UDA stack the observe you know
each of these different elements of that
stack the AI stack is sort of organized
similarly at the bottom layer is the
sensing or perception layer and
increasingly that layer
is in hardware and this is about audio
video multi model text based perception
and that those signals that are
perceived are then that's equals to the
observation uh the Oda stack and that
perception then feeds into a signal
processing layer which tries to make
sense of what's being actually perceived
and then that then
feeds into this learning layer and
for a long long time now I mean there's
been tremendous developments in the
learning stack which in itself as you
know has has had tremendous amount of
progress particularly in the field of
deep learning and neural network
architectures
everybody's been excited about what's
happened since the release of Chad GPT
and these so-called large language
models they are all at the at the
learning layer of being able to take
vast amounts of corpora so for instance
chat gpt4 was trained on 570 gigabytes
of of text and other kinds of corporate
be it code from GitHub be it images from
Getty Images video so it's this immense
amount of input that's gone into the
training of these neural networks and
these models have grown in size as well
the chat gpd4 as what's called 170
billion parameters in the neural network
so that learning layer as the size of
the training corpora and the size of
these models have increased the capacity
and the capabilities of these models
ranges from you know the kinds of
capabilities you've seen exhibited by
chat GPT and chat GPT is one of many
large language models Google has
something called Bard and there's lots
of different kinds of powerful models
that are being developed by
organizations I was with at an emerging
Tech event a couple of weeks ago and
Adobe has its own large language model
for images and video and increasingly
you're seeing the integration of these
learning layers and the output of those
capabilities in personal productivity
tools be it the Microsoft stack as
Microsoft has announced or adobe or
Google Mail
Etc
the learning stack then feeds into a
decision-making layer so what is it
that's been learned how can it actually
support decision making
um where you're using the patterns that
have been learned unimportantly even
potentially causally understanding the
relationships between what's being
observed and what decision to take and
this is where it could be a very useful
decision support device uh particularly
to the human in and this is the human
the loop but it could equally well
potentially support decision making
autonomously that's the decision-making
layer the decision making layer then on
top of that resides the action layer so
the stack then at a very minimum you
could think of it as having these four
layers the perception layer the learning
layer the decision making layer and the
action layer and these different layers
can be deployed
via the Enterprise it can be deployed at
the edge
conditional on the constraints of the
technology imagine a large language
model today I don't think we have the
the devices to actually deploy it
directly on a mobile device but you
could because it takes immense amount of
compute and data power to train these
models but once trained could you
imagine an image of these models that
could be
put on a device that could be on a
disconnected not connected to the
network not the way we use chat GPD
today with an API but imagine it being
on a mobile device disconnected that
could potentially change the nature of
the deployment in the edge for the kinds
of use cases that were being discussed
earlier today and
um
the nature of these capabilities if you
think of this is what I've described
entirely is a technology stack and an
associate Associated set of capabilities
the biggest challenges has been have
been how do you get people trained with
the skills to be able to effectively use
this technology stack so just to give
you an example of something we work like
I said with the US Army they send us AI
technicians there's technician training
there are officers being trained for
being data Engineers or data scientists
and then the leadership has to
understand how best to put this
trained human capital to use in the
field using this technology if if you
train these folks and then put them back
to work doing exactly the same old thing
they did before they did the training
that's not much point and therefore the
the Futures command training set if you
think of this is a pyramid at the top
end of the pyramid are the phds and the
Masters uh then come a very large number
of people are going to be deployers and
then there are lots of operators that's
the AI technicians the officers being
data scientists and data Engineers plus
people who are actually going to create
the tech so you need a very holistic
View and I think of this as a human
capital stack that has to stand side by
side with the technology stack to
actually get the most value out of this
so let me stop here Ted and I'm sure
there'll be lots of opportunities to
build done this discussion all right
thank you so much I'm going to try to
save myself and all my questions uh for
just a minute because I want to
incorporate uh some of the other
expertise that we have so just shifting
from AI for a moment uh to Quantum
Computing I was also struck uh by Mr
innis's comments about uh you know just
the challenge of grappling with emerging
Technologies uh with unclear time
Horizons and impact and Quantum
Computing strikes me as an area where
this is a particularly acute challenge
so uh very grateful to have Dr girvin
with us he's been a member of the Yale
faculty since 2001 he's the Eugene
Higgins professor of physics and applied
physics he's had some significant
University Administration roles here
including as Deputy Provost for research
kind of overseeing Yale's overall
strategic planning and resource
allocation and Personnel decisions with
respect to The Sciences across Yale and
he returned to this to full-time
teaching at Yale in 2017 but that's not
all that he does he is of course himself
an exceptional uh scholar and in the
theoretical studies of quantum uh many
particle systems he's been part of
setting up the Yale Quantum Institute
which is a really significant effort uh
which is sort of developing uh you know
a practical architecture for
construction of a quantum computer which
has won numerous uh Acclaim uh both uh
nationally as well as around the world
and in addition to his teaching he was
the founder and still as a member of the
center for Quantum Advantage which is a
part of the Brookhaven National
Laboratory and a department of energy
funded effort to try to harness a better
National approach to understanding both
the risks as well as the opportunities
that Quantum Computing might hold so
Steve I wanted to bring you into the
conversation with respect to Quantum you
know this is an audience with varying
levels of knowledge about this uh
promises as well as all sorts of
hyperbole perhaps as well that's been
out been thrown out there before so
maybe help us think about what you see
as the most uh you know significant
applications of quantum Computing and
their National Security implications
both benefits and risks and you know
what a military audience should know and
start thinking about as you grapple with
the timelines and your outstanding
research in this area
sure
thanks very much Ted
[Music]
so you guys have been throwing a lot of
acronyms at me today so I feel like I
should start with a little bit of
vocabulary and maybe some historical
context about what is this all about so
um you know the
one of the main pillars of physics is
classical mechanics the theory of
invented by Isaac Newton more than 300
years ago for that determines you know
the orbits of satellites and missiles
the the orbit of the moon and so forth
It's fantastically successful Theory
um and but it only applies to sort of
large objects something goes wrong when
you get down to the scale of individual
atoms or individual electrons
and uh we needed a new Theory beginning
about a hundred years ago the quantum
theory was invented
uh and that led to what I'll call the
first Quantum Revolution beginning a
century ago that brought us the
transistor
the laser and the atomic clock which led
to GPS
and the entire 20th century technology
Revolution was built on these first
Quantum devices
but there's now a second quantum
Revolution underway it has huge promise
maybe
a lot of hype for sure very uncertain uh
timelines
but it has the potential to be in
possibly as big a revolution as the one
that brought us the 20th century Tech
Revolution and it's based on a not a new
theory of quantum but a new
understanding of this hundred-year-old
Theory and the role of
information content in Quantum States
and we now realize that the transistor
the laser and the atomic clock
while Quantum machines they don't
harness the full power that is actually
available in Quantum machines and
Quantum technology
and so the sort of three use cases that
are relevant to this audience are
quantum sensing it turns out in in the
quantum theory you have to think deeply
about what is a measurement what is
detecting something
and it's more complicated and subtle
than In classical physics because when
you measure something it changes
but it's important to you for the
detection of extremely weak signals
small magnetic anomalies near overhead
above submarines
gravitational anomalies over caves and
mountains
uh weak radio signals Etc
the kind of quantum limited amplifiers
that we build for our quantum computers
could easily they work in cell phone
frequency ranges they can easily detect
uh or perhaps even be overloaded by a
cell phone on the moon
um the second is quantum encryption and
communication current cryptographic
Protocols are more or less uniformly
based on the difficulty of some math
problem solving some math problem
uh Quantum encryption
security is based on uh our inability to
violate the laws of physics that's a
different
um different setup
and then finally Quantum computation the
ability to process information in
completely new ways
compared to the traditional what I'll
call classical computers it's a
completely new model of computation
certain
problems which computer scientists
classify as
difficult or exponentially hard as you
raise the size of some database are not
necessarily exponentially hard on if you
have if you can build a quantum computer
so it's not it's their their advantages
do not come from having a faster clock
speed often the clock speed at least
today is slower than the highly
developed wrap fast classical computers
we have today but it's a completely
different model which for certain
classes of problems that can be solved
more readily on Quantum Hardware
so for example we're in
you only need a few thousand Quantum
bits to do something extremely
interesting and Powerful with a quantum
computer you don't need
the kind of scale of terabytes and
things that you have in today's
computers on the other hand we don't
even have that yet we're in the very
early stages of the technology the
technology is
imperfect makes lots of Errors the the
number of calculations we can do or
calculational steps we can do before an
error happens is very small uh
um a few thousand perhaps today
so a Grand Challenge is to figure out
how to do error correction we also need
to have a greater understanding of what
kind of algorithms uh can be invented
that are what what kind of problems can
be a solved more efficiently with this
Hardware we understand something about
optimization problems and simulation
problems and machine learning
classification problems and things like
that
but I I want to be very clear I've heard
a lot about big data and high data rates
and things that probably big data
problems and machine learning problems
while in principle there are quantum
advantages that that will be the last
area
of application for technical reasons
that we need for exponentially big data
sets we actually need exponentially many
Quantum bits and we just don't have
those yet
um in terms of timeline
um
Quantum sensing and Quantum encryption
are here now I mean there are even
companies you can purchase from but with
lots of limitations in terms of uh
uh bandwidth and lack of uh being
portable or battle hardened and so forth
but the the technology is here
computation
I don't know uh I'm I I've been saying
at least 10 years for a while now
and uh I I just given that the people
who invented the transistor the laser
and the atomic clock had no idea what
they were going to be used for I
hesitate to say what whether this is
going or how quickly
uh
and so I'm reasonably sure they're going
to be you know just as there were AI
Winters they're going to be Quantum
Winters but I'm I'm somewhat optimistic
that the government is presently taking
a pretty sensible Olive government
long-term coordinated approach to
investing in this research area
uh so I'm as long as they continue that
uh for and our patient I think this is
going to lead to
um uh really interesting new
technologies exactly in what form and
what the best use cases will be
I you know it's that's the future in
which I'm still unsure about great uh
thank you so much I'll come back to you
with some questions I'm sure the
audience has their own as well so
turning to this question then of uh how
to incorporate and adapt emerging
Technologies uh into business operations
I would really like to get Mike Hayes's
thoughts on this and and reactions uh
both to the technical discussion we just
had on AI and Quantum as well as Mr
innis's comments before Mike Hayes is uh
vmware's Chief Operating Officer I think
many of you are familiar with VMware uh
it's uh you know one of the world's
leading uh cloud computing companies uh
valuation of over 60 billion dollars and
in that uh capacity you know he's
responsible for worldwide business
operations uh passion uh for sort of
driving agility and excellence in in the
customer Mission as well which I'm sure
will hear about prior to joining the
private sector Mr Hayes spent 20 years
in the U.S Navy Seals multiple combat
tours in Bosnia Kosovo Iraq and
Afghanistan at some significant command
levels as well as some White House
policy experience director for defense
policy and strategy at the National
Security Council and I'll just put a
plug for his best-selling book as well
never enough a Navy SEAL Commander
living a life of Excellence agility
meaning and I'm putting a plug because
he donates all profits to pay off the
mortgages for gold star families in
which I think you're on the seventh
which is what you mentioned to me just
now so uh Mike I I'm interested in your
reactions uh from where you sit now at
VMware and overseeing uh you know such a
significant cloud computing company just
on the verge of this next level of data
processing Revolution but also having
the the public sector and the military
service that that you've also had and
and those experiences of uh inhabiting
both those worlds so thank you for being
with us Ted thank you for having me
first of all after listening to doctors
girvin and Krishna I'm not sure I'm at
the right conference uh these guys are
way smarter and I'm humbled to be here
I'm just a simple guy who's wearing a
kerchief in his pocket for the first
time in his 52-year life so
um you know I got this for Christmas and
and tried it out today on all of you so
um so anyways that makes me super
nervous to be here hey uh thanks to Yale
serious seriously for putting this on a
couple of quick thoughts look I'm just a
simple guy that thinks about things in a
very simple way I think the art form of
really thinking about technology is how
do you make complicated things simple
and um for me when I'm running the you
know Global operations for VMware I
really think about uh things in a couple
ways first of all what I would say is is
technology is awesome but keep in mind
that technology is a means to an end you
know and so technology is just driving
and creating value and so just like when
you're in the military on an operation
and you know one of the things we got
better at post 911 was working backward
from the outcome we were trying to
achieve right it wasn't like oh my gosh
I want to go on a mission and let me go
put all this training to work whether no
matter what part of the military you're
in it's what effect are we trying to
cause and then how do we take the least
amount of risk along the way so that we
can go achieve that that's no different
at VMware and see if you think about the
pro the product development life cycle
like right now we have we spend four
plus billion dollars a year in research
and development and and how do we think
about how we spend our own you know our
own economics it's it's not complicated
it's there's a a market for something
that we're trying to achieve how do we
as an organization coalesce around the
what we are trying to do and from there
then it gets to the how so if the vision
is the the where the the strategy is
really the how and what what matters a
lot to me is to think about you know not
me working another two or another 26
hours a day that's not going to move the
needle on anything
I'm in charge of a system and so when I
think about a system technology is a key
part of it but you also have to have
process and policy and so what it takes
somebody to step back and and be able to
put together and do the systems-based
thinking to unlock the value that's in
your organization for example you know
when I'm a commander of a special
operations task force and I'm you know
in the talk or The Jock or whatever you
want to call it you know I I walk in and
I've intentionally designed myself out
of a job why that's how I can sit there
and think about the negative space not
the positive space of what's Happening
everybody's already gravitating to what
their job is already in the negative
space that's where all of the
opportunity and the risk is so when I
walk into a Fortune 500 company now and
I say who here is in charge of what
we're not doing it doesn't compute
because people aren't thinking about
that negative space and so when you
think about creating a system how do you
systematically go after opportunities
and value Creation in that negative
space you know for me one of the things
that I I enjoyed from from Bill's
presentation was really the
crystallization and I'm going to over
overly simplify here but if you think
about the cocoms they are driving
outcomes and when you think about
functional providers like a Socom or any
sort of unit in the U.S you are truly
providing a capability and so think
about the the the world when you do the
AI pixie dust what's the outcome you're
trying to achieve or what's the function
that you're trying to maximize but be
really crisp and laser-like in your
thinking around what are you doing and
why and so uh for me I think that's what
what really breaks down a lot is is the
governance and the systemization of what
you're doing VMware has 40 000 employees
and so if we don't get the the system
right then we're going to fail and so
what does that mean go back to Bill's
presentation and when you look at you
know from you know satellites to subs
and you think about the points in
between you are creating there is a
system there and so sure any single node
in that system is important but way way
way more important is the architecture
of that system and so if you think about
architecture how does information flow
back and forth across a system so that
any single node can be can underperform
in this in an individ an individual
fails but the organization doesn't and
so as we think about these great you
know Quantum compute AI Etc what to me
is really important is is having the
architecture right and I'm a little
biased because I mean I'm at VMware and
that's what we do but you think about
how do you enable an organization to
have a really clean application layer
how do you have a really clean data
layer and um you know one of the things
that I've just overseen is the complete
rebuild of our entire Enterprises data
Foundation we have structured and
unstructured data how do you get the
most out of that well you know running a
transformation for a fortune you would
have a Fortune 500 company it's not sexy
to go say hi we're going to go fix the
data because your sales teams and your
your product you know Engineers Etc they
don't see the oil that is in the engine
and that makes the car go and so what I
I really would encourage people to think
about is really the underlying system
because if you don't get that Foundation
right then anything else is a capability
at you know whether it's on-prem with a
hyperscaler on the edge sitting with an
MSP wherever you are that is really a
function of your foundation so my point
is you know always prepare for the the
thing that you can't see coming and so
when you're writing requirements think
about to to Ted's Point think about
building agility into your system
because by the time something comes to
life there will be a million more use
cases you didn't think of from when you
wrote the requirements and so did you
create something that is fluid and
functional that can be not just used for
a point in time but to be you be used
for you know the many many years to come
so it's a relatively simple point but
it's one that often gets missed great uh
thanks so much Mike I want to bring in
uh Sam as well uh of course also one of
our uh El graduates so it's great to
have him
um back as I mentioned before at the
beginning as one of our late career uh
Yale undergraduate students what we call
our Eli Whitney students Sam came from
the Special Operations military
Community to Yale for a late year ba and
has since gone on to utilize that
background for some incredible uh work
that he's doing in strategy and growth
Consulting he is currently corporate
strategic growth director from periton
Corporation and there he's managing uh
the growth of about a 12 billion dollar
Enterprise pipeline that's trying to
create U.S government opportunities in
defense space intelligence side fiber
civilian and health sectors of the firm
managing a lot of complex strategies and
operations in this regard and in
particular in a perspective that maybe
is a little bit different than Mike's is
working with the startup Community as
well uh in the AI and emerging Tech
space so I wanted to maybe bring in your
thoughts on that we've talked about the
talent pipeline the acquisition
challenges uh what is sort of some of
the principal challenges confronting
startups in this space particularly as
you think about their potential
application to the defense industrial
base and then still having you know the
major players as well who are
established but you know there's a
there's a role for for integrating new
approaches as well so how do you Scope
and think about that challenge and and
what you think is most relevant for for
this audience no thank you uh Ted and uh
it's uh wonderful to be back here of
course but before I begin I just want to
give a big Shout shout out to Mike for
putting all this thing together I know
it required a lot of hard work because
I've been there brother so no thank you
so I just want to give her a friend
[Applause]
yes
thank you so much and uh and Ted you and
uh the leadership here at Jackson as
well thank you for keep on hosting these
events as far as it is so crucial for
our national security to have this
engagements happen every year uh to
really get that going and you know
there's the thing that I'm seeing right
now in Washington is that the need for
Innovation every command every peo
everybody is coming to the industrial
base and saying hey guys give us real
Innovation we don't want the repackage
solutions that you guys have offered for
the last 20 years what is happening
where is this Innovation coming from and
one of the things that I've been leading
is really the Outreach to the startup
communities companies two three man
operations brilliant computer scientists
Quantum physicists Etc that are trying
to do business with the government but
don't have a cage code don't have a
facility clearance how do you get
involved with working with the Pentagon
or the IC so uh you know there's many
companies that are leading those
initiatives and and I have to say the
Pentagon has done a great job with diu
and establishing an office down in uh in
the valley and everything which is
moving the needle but not fast enough so
we're actively looking at firms that can
provide Solutions need solutions to
really
sit on that overarching
capability set that is affecting us like
near Pier and all this other stuff
that's happening but also the unexpected
type of issues that are arising just
these days I mean recently we saw the
balloon Fiasco that was happening across
Montana and everywhere and everybody was
like how can this happen that a Chinese
balloon or is able to come into our
airspace Etc hey you know that's what
electronic warfare is all about what are
we doing about creating those electronic
force fields Etc there's a lot of
research going on and I'm currently
working with the good Folks at Georgia
Tech Research Institute they're doing
some great work out there and that's
actually being implemented at certain
areas with appsoc et cetera but
this engagement is also morphing as well
where we're seeing so many threats
evolve
and the next
generation or the current generation of
operators need to be hybrid trained in
my opinion they need to have
core capabilities not expert level but
at least conversational level at Ocean
at even human I'm a human guy and I
think it's very important when you're
out in the field if you're disconnected
you can still function and sustain in
that environment individually and that
is very crucial that is something that
I'm very pushy on with the folks down in
Tampa and Bragg and I really want to see
those expertise develop and being
trained for the operator so they're
never
dependent on one individual back at the
HQ level but at the same time I want to
say that
all the stuff that's happening about
uh Ai and ML and everything that's all
great but we should not forget the basic
fundamentals as well human is key I'm
going to put a plug in for human just
because uh because we saw this in the
90s and the 80s just because as the 80s
we you know we're launching all these
satellites and everything hey no problem
we can see anything from anywhere great
but we couldn't tap into the terror
networks in Philippines Etc in Pakistan
Afghanistan areas so we need to keep
that capability alive but at the same
time we need to increase and
reduce this Talent train that we're
experiencing within the NASA community
that we need to recruit individuals and
recruit the Next Generation and not just
talk about okay hey we're going to
recruit from these communities et cetera
but also be competitive about it right
and incr you know there's a thing hey
give incentivized but also expedite
Facebook or Google gives an offer letter
and you start Monday
clearance level at the NSA is going to
take a year that kid is not waiting
they're not waiting and we're losing
individuals we're losing talent that way
and that is a big concern right now I
was sitting with
um Rob Joyce not long ago and I was like
sir you know we have to pick this up we
have to have
programs at colleges that are immediate
hires that are helping be the next
coding or mathematicians Etc at the
National Security Agency because it's so
crucial
and um
it's something that is very concerning
but on the tech side specifically
speaking one thing that I'm very excited
about is space all the stuff and
activity that's happening in space these
days just on Sunday we launched
um uh the first tranche uh program
that's happening cubesats they're
amazing I think that's going to be a
game changer with the ISR platforms to
provide that continuous monitoring
that's going in a hybrid platform in a
hybrid model where you're looking at a
Target but also you can launch assets
too it doesn't require long flyovers
Etc within the indo-paycom region
specifically but these are exciting new
you know technologies that are being
developed but at the same time all
technology is great but if we don't have
the people that are out there execute
these amazing Technologies that's a
problem and that is something we need to
keep that yeah please uh thank you so
much I'm gonna ask a follow-up to folks
here and then we'll we'll incorporate uh
all of your comments as well uh Dr
Christian I want to zoom back in on uh
maybe one or two of the layers that you
focused on namely at decision making and
action with respect to AI because we did
have a question from Mr Bergen earlier
about a human in the loop right and so
of course the Department of Defense has
this new revised directive now on
Automation and uh this concept of of
meaningful control and so you know just
based on your own uh research and
teaching and the programs that that
you're building at CMU you know what's
the right way to think about this
question of human in the loop we throw
around so many of these terms a lot on
AI uh responsible use ethical use
meaningful control you know what are
some of the the best practices in your
view in this space that are most
relevant for this audience which may be
ultimately you hoping to utilize AI you
know in human machine teams you know to
make you know significant kinetic
decisions and so just give us I'm
thinking uh on this question I think
that might be particularly helpful uh
thank you it does it was on actually
yeah thank you Ted
um so uh
so two things to keep in mind more
broadly about AI
is the technology even though from what
you read you might think it's some magic
button that will work perfectly all the
time
in all situations and that's not the
case
um it it's it's really good oftentimes
on narrow tasks that's where it's been
shown to be particularly good and
it's oftentimes brittle when you start
deviating from the data on which it was
trained on this is called Drift it's
there's this idea that you train a model
on data and if and if what you're seeing
in the world is not representative of
what it was trained on you might not get
good recommendations good decisions so
one is to recognize that robustness
brittleness these are things to be
really well educated about so it's
almost like having a what these are
often called Data cards or model cards
where for every AI there's a need to
have metadata about you know in what
range is this AI to be totally trusted
what's the confidence interval if you
will around this AI That's sort of an
important aspect now given the
consequentiality of the decision that
you need to make I mean if it's about
popping an ad in on somebody's computer
and if I if the AIM made a mistake in
showing you an ad that you're unhappy
with that's not super consequential but
on the other hand if it's a
consequential decision that has to do
with people's lives or the kinds of
services you're providing them or in
even where people's lives are at stake
in the kinds of situations that you all
are engaged in those tasks and the bar
is very high in terms of ensuring
you know are the values that we as a
society you as an organization have
articulated and this is where the
responsible use part comes in so you
have accuracy Effectiveness efficiency
you want the the war fighter to be
better equipped to be able to make these
decisions in uh and gain situational
awareness be able to deal and digest
data that's that's coming at a rate that
without the support they're not able to
provide all of that is on the plus side
of the column on the negative side of
the column might be how do I trust what
it is that this thing is producing and
how do I ensure that
what it is that is producing is Abe
invalidated verified Etc and two are
there in the societal setting in
domestic societal setting these are
often referred to in terms of you know
ensuring Equity or you in this case it
might have to do with ensuring that the
values that you have that you have to
sort of balance
are taken into account so oftentimes let
me give you a societal example I'm I'm
familiar with one might be asked to make
a trade-off so oftentimes a trade-off in
AI governance that arises is
how much is it going to how much are you
willing to trade off on accuracy
to get an additional unit of equity and
in your case replays Equity with you
know the appropriate Dimension that
you're you're concerned about or vice
versa if I can I get more of both can I
be more accurate and more Equitable or
is there really a trade-off and if I'm
going to make that trade-off what are
the weights that people are going to
place on these things and who comes up
with these weights is there guidance and
Doctrine that's going to tell you that
this is how you're going to have to make
these trade-offs so I I think the the
high level point that I want to make is
irrespective of whether it's generative
AI the chat GPT like technology which
makes a lot of errors it's not perfect
by any means but it does move the needle
on a number of tasks that
that you might be interested in using it
for so that's the accuracy or efficiency
or Effectiveness under the dimension
you're always asking the question by
deploying this AI
when can I trust it so this is the part
about validity verification Etc and then
when I actually use it how can I use it
in a way where it's in aligned with my
values and that's where this trade-off
governance question comes up between
improving accuracy and efficiency and
this Equity point that I made the larger
point that you oftentimes see firms
making this decision about when they
deploy AI is I think Mike made the point
that at the end of the day all of this
is means to an end it's absolutely true
in let me give you an example from
Healthcare in healthcare they take the
system as a whole I don't care about
whether this algorithm is fair or
accurate or whatever oftentimes it's a
pipeline I'm interested in the
performance of the system as a whole and
in healthcare there's something called
the quintuple aim there are five
Dimensions along which you rate any
Healthcare delivery system is the
patient how do you even is the patient
doing better is the provider doing
better is the community doing better and
is those Dimensions those are called the
quintuple aims of any Healthcare System
might be useful to think about is there
the equivalent of a quintuple aim
like like that should there be something
that should guide which is multiple
criteria that should guide the
assessment and evaluation of AI based
systems when AI is deployed in the kinds
of contexts that you're uh that you're
working with and responsible use comes
down to how do I play with the
parameters who's empowered to do that
one and two how can I assess and
evaluate the system in terms of their
objectives and the aims that matter to
me most so that that's how I think about
it great thank you so much Steve I think
we're still a little bit off from the
use of quantum Computing for life or
death decision making of the sort that
this audience is accustomed to making on
a daily basis but you know we're still
not that far away from being able to
scope with some of of the risks might be
and so just give us a sense of what what
does concern you most from the National
Security perspective is it the the loss
of secure Communications there's
obviously a lot of hyperboles
surrounding you know whether other
nations might develop in this area you
know China of course has a very
aggressive National Quantum plan I'm
curious if you have any thoughts on
China's own activity in this space that
might be of relevance to this group
that's possibly really the only nation
level State capable of competing
are the threats in your mind sort of
specific in terms of what some of the
impacts could be or is it more this
General fear of kind of a loss of
national competitiveness as a new Next
Generation technology you know enters
the scene a decade from now
thanks Ted so China is indeed
investing heavily it's very hard to say
from the outside you know how
efficiently Etc I mean lots of Justice
in this country many things have been
relabeled Quantum to seek funding from
the government I I know that's true in
China
but they're investing very heavily
in terms of
communication and encryption there's
there's sort of offense and defense and
and Quantum can contribute to both sides
in the end
uh uh if if all of this can be made to
work well
um
privacy is enhanced because there are
forms of quantum communication such that
even an adversary with Quantum
capabilities will be unable to uh to
break the encryption on the other hand
a lot of current encryption is based on
the difficulty of of solving certain
mathematical problems without without a
knowledge of a key or other other a crib
to get in
and uh it's perfectly possible and
presumably is going on that much of this
encrypted communication is currently
being captured and written to disks and
could be in decrypted uh using Quantum
Hardware when uh we're not close to
being able to apply Shores algorithm to
do this for example now but could happen
uh within you know 10 or 20 years so
there's a lot of interest in
uh what's called post Quantum encryption
uh it's classical ordinary mathematical
encryption but with the different
algorithms that are designed to be
difficult even for quantum computers so
there's a lot of
concerns I guess both on offense and
defense connected with this technology
um
the yeah the players in the world are
are China
the US and a few countries in Europe
Switzerland Germany Austria Sweden
primarily
um
and
I think it's
very important for to take a long-term
view of sort of national investments in
this just because it's it's extremely
uncertain there isn't a guaranteed
payoff but we need to be you know if
there is a breakthrough we need to have
the workforce and the technical
expertise and the people and the and the
ecosystem
to really respond to that
by what Steve said in in all the things
that I said about responsible use of AI
one of the things to keep in mind is
that the adversary may not be
responsible
um so uh so when you think about that
setting what would it take by way of
Technology by way of human capital by
way of systems that we have that would
allow for us to compete and out compete
an adversary who might be irresponsible
that's a a good framing for us to think
about as well that's very good thank you
uh Mike I want to get your thoughts on
uh one other area that Mr Ennis touched
on which was uh cyber security and
supply chain Security in particular
obviously uh managing such a vast cloud
computing uh Enterprises you do you know
the attack surface is vast right the
adversaries uh seem to be growing in
capability diffusing in Cape ability
from the most sophisticated State actors
to a wide range of kind of gray
actors or even non-state actors in this
space so you know emerging Technologies
including AI of course have the ability
both to accelerate uh the cyber security
concerns right but also maybe hold out
some opportunities for detection and
mitigation and and building resilience
and just kind of curious how you grapple
with this Challenge from your Vantage
Point in sort of both the risk as well
as the benefit Ted it's a great question
like you heard I spent some time in DC
so I'm really good at not asking the
question I was not answering the
question I was asked but the question
that I wish I was asked
um we'll come back to the Cyber thing I
think there's an elemental point to what
you're saying that is universally
applicable to whether it's cyber or any
other technology you know if you think
back you know when the bicycle was
invented parents got really nervous that
their kids were going to be able to go
too far away and they were losing
control
you know most of us in this room
remember you know we we started
navigating when we learned to drive with
Rand McNally maps and now we're on Waze
you know if it's map Encompass you know
I was a silver ranger in a you know grid
Square guy and now everybody else is
using these little you know handheld
GPS's instantly you know we always have
a little bit of a Nostalgia for the past
at the same time you can't live without
the present and so if you think about
those the the universal uh truths of
Technology advancement there's always a
little bit of oh no we can't let go of
the past
but we can't live without the present
and so that's a really important thing
to remember that as we're talking about
models to Peter's Point earlier around
like the the previous discussion around
you know when will the computers be
doing everything and we just be watching
you know that's um that's that is coming
if you really think about what are we
doing think about the world in three
simple layers you've got data you've got
logic and then you've got an opinion or
or a decision and so you very crisply
need to separate your data and your
logic and your opinion and all you're
really doing mostly is program unpacking
logic and compute and digitizing it you
know when I was the commander of Special
Operations task force Southeast 2000
people running everything in in in
Southeastern Afghanistan in 2012. you
know I personally was responsible for
1100 times clearing you know 500 pound J
dams from aircraft to to drop on the
ground okay so what now what am I all
I'm doing is a decision-making system
and so if you really think about it all
I'm doing is unpacking logic of when to
say yes and when to say no that is Dr
Christian and Dr Gervin could could
program that in a split second all we
need to do is get from like what's
happening not just in my brain but in my
units Collective you know brain and
getting that down that is very
replicable now the thing is with model
drift to Dr Christian's point you have
to be very careful because at some point
there will be wrong decisions and so
when they're the the the uh we won't be
defined whether or not there are wrong
decisions we will be defined by how we
handle the wrong decisions that's the
most critical piece just like if we ever
did something wrong with uh and I'm
proud to say we never harmed anybody we
shouldn't harm on those 1100
air-to-ground drops but let's just say
we did you know how do you diagnose down
to the root cause what the failure was
that feedback is not different than the
product that we're developing at VMware
there's a product for vmware's uh for
for our products excuse me a market for
our products there's product Market fit
that you have gaps in between where we
are and where we want to be for the
market and then oh by the way the
Market's always moving how do we
systematically get after that well
sometimes we're wrong A lot of times
we're wrong but as long as we're right
more than we're wrong but how we will
that's okay we'll be defined with how we
handle the wrongs the wrongs have to
feed back into that Loop so with cyber
look we're going to have I I ran a two
and a half billion dollar p l for
financial services at cognizant before
being at VMware that was a you know we
had a ransomware attack where everything
was shut down you know and when UBS is
is uh calculating their end of day P L's
at every desk and then rolling it up to
the p l for the whole firm and saying um
what what are the margin calls that we
need to make because there were some bad
you know somebody some of their
customers or clients made bad trades
like like that's a risk decision that's
really critical for for a big bank so so
we if we get that wrong how do we make
sure that we enable the the the learning
that goes with that so with cyber
you know we have things go wrong how do
we get to the root cause of what
happened and simultaneously be pressed
forward one other quick point and I I
absolutely infinitely respect the VC
community and and the comments that Sam
made I would also just offer a counter
and a flip side to it
um even in the previous uh there was a
question around uh you know VC we hold
up the word in the military we just kind
of munge VC with private Equity be
careful because the VC world is all is
not usually Enterprise grade software
I'm a huge Pro component of feeding that
into the Department of Defense the
National Security Community Etc we have
to have that however comma you don't
often find sock 2 compliant software in
the VC space and so as you as you look
to proliferate where we need to go as a
national security Community you have to
make sure you connect back to Enterprise
grade software that's going to be able
to do well at scale and it's not
different than the Cyber firm's head
well I mean to your point
um
you know there needs to be
accountability
right if if a d IU vendor is developing
a product that Socom is buying and it
doesn't work
as we heard in the previous session you
know there needs to be accountability
for that with that vendor uh that's
where the procurement policy making is
so crucial that because these are Nat's
cycle level type of uh threats that
we're facing and and if that product
were to fail with a unit and it deployed
in a foreign enemy territory
wow
that kind of thing and and to your point
VCS are absolutely they're looking at
first go to market et cetera that kind
of thing and they're not taking their
cutting Corners in a way uh but that's
why you know our the technical
evaluation Board needs to be just as
where I have to say ATL is leading in a
lot of ways with procurement and
devising new mechanisms to provide that
best technical value to the Warfighter
and holding folks accountable too and
and they're doing that by bringing in
Industry experts to actually
uh examine that product that they're you
know as a third party not them they're
bringing in some professor and saying
hey sort of can you analyze this and can
I jump on that on top of that sorry the
um if I'm in Bill's role the thing that
I really want to make sure is happening
is you have two types of testing before
you roll something out there's quality
engineering QE testing making sure it is
the engineering if you run all the
combinations and permutations of what
can go wrong and that that is often
short-stroked in in any product company
because you get compressed and you're
like late and that's the last step and
you're like oh my gosh how can we do
what we were supposed to do in four
weeks in just a week I do that just to
be clear and I get pushed against the
wall and sometimes I need to make a hard
decision do we miss our deadline or do
we say nope we're going to test for four
weeks sometimes I choose one sometimes I
choose the other but the other part of
it that often gets overlooked is uat
user acceptance testing and so going
back to your customers your clients and
saying all right before we really Harden
this product we want your feedback from
a a consumer perspective and and don't
forget the dod the National Security
Community is a consumer that can drive
the development of products
and field testing too where is it going
to be deployed will that product work in
that deployment area that is not
happening and um
we'll get better
let's open it up to uh questions and
Thoughts From the audience
come on it's about my kerchief
[Laughter]
laughs
I'll ask a question oh we'll get both of
you go ahead yeah
structured and unstructured data
I can and I'll be I'll be quick and glad
to take it offline the um you know
VMware is a 25 year old Enterprise what
happens for you know I'll talk about
VMware but it's also metaphorically any
large Enterprise I don't care if you're
Amazon Google Microsoft whatever you
have Tangled knots sometimes in these
Enterprises that are have just been
created because number one is Success
can create an ability to just go buy the
next thing and layer it on in in the
proverbial you know spaghetti plate just
gets more and more larger and more
Tangled and so for us we never step back
and actually like actually really
um uh created the governance around our
data and so we and we had poor hierarchy
meaning what lives where in what
ecosystem and how do you go how do you
get after that and so what we
operate number one is we created a
vision for a new world we ran on the old
world and then there's a lot of tension
in any organization to say why aren't
you paying attention to me because I
need more paper clips and chewing gum to
go run the old stuff you have to swing I
I have limited you know a finite amount
of resources people to to either run the
company or transform the company so I
need to make a decision how much
allocation do I spend toward running
toward transform the simple math problem
the more you put on transform the faster
you're going to do it but the louder the
complaints are going to be around the
run and so you know I try to get that
right over the last couple years
sometimes I got it right sometimes I got
it wrong but um but where we popped out
on the other side was a modern data
architecture with with Incredible
governance and and hierarchy so that now
we can really benefit from the things
that Dr Christian is talking about and
sitting on top of of models that can say
you know look at what's a customer's
propensity to buy they already have
product number a are they going to buy
products c f or L you know and and these
are the kinds of things that can
ultimately help us drive more top-line
revenue or save costs and therefore
improve the bottom line but why is that
important for the National Security
Community it's because think about the
world in a GDP framework remember it's
just labor times productivity equals the
total economic output of of the world
you know there are a lot of us in here
with Incredible pasts and you know at
the end of the day though we are we are
largely Commodities where our government
can go buy more of us if they have more
money a lot of us are very expensive
Commodities but we're Commodities
nonetheless and so more GDP equals more
capacity for our nation to create more
you know special people like in this
room or to pay down debt or to buy more
Health Care More education more whatever
and so driving productivity for the
nation really is job number one
just make a quick comment to follow one
of the biggest challenges with the
structured and unstructured data is
traditionally our view is uh this data
is being used to train models to uh for
quote unquote good purposes
um but these data can also be subject to
manipulation and become a type of a
vector for attack so you could have an
adversary change or a change the nature
of your Corpus or inject stuff into your
Corpus that then gets your model to
behave differently than you would want
it to or the model itself is something
that is subject to potential attacks so
that's why I think the systems view of
the problem is really important to take
rather than just look at one algorithm
or what the data is you need to go all
the way from problem formulation to data
to the methods all the way out to what
comes out on the other side can I ask
you a question is that legal of course
how do you know when it's broken down so
it the the big question here is when you
have
um so this is where you have to have if
you have ground truth
meaning you know in some cases what the
ground truth is then the question is
when there is variance is there a way in
which you can check back as to why the
model is not working like it's supposed
to in the case where you don't have
ground truth this becomes a hugely
challenging problem uh but this data
contamination problem which is the
problem we're talking about where you
have an adversary attacking the the data
sets that you're training on itself is
something that you can bootstrap your AI
around and ask the question and it's the
data contaminated or not it doesn't have
to be a binary thing but uh it's it's
that's itself is a subjective uh you can
it's a topic of study well I mean data
manipulation is so crucial these days
just because in the ocean World we're
seeing the rise of deep fakes and
everything that's happening right now
and tools are so important to
effectively corroborate that report if
that is happening or this is a fake
report or is this a real report what is
happening and what are the actual
core sources that is being reported from
because there's so much haziness and
fuzziness that's happening on the news
and what's on my dad is on Facebook and
he's like did you see this report I'm
like Dad no stop you know it's just one
of those things because there's so much
misinformation being pumped by state
actors but also commercial actors as
well too so that is something when it
becomes the challenge that Sam speaks
about I think is when you have this type
of misinformation getting bumped into
the system and that gets then added back
into the Corpus then you get the
training of these models being affected
by what's been added in well like the
hallucination of Chad gbt that could be
for all together
yeah but Chad gbt is just it's uh
putting a response back in a very nice
language but it's also taking rument as
well that's out there from forums Etc
whatever and saying hey this is this is
actually what's going on no that is not
because right now in the bottom one that
prompt does appear you don't see any
sources right but we're going to see
chat GPT also evolve right now it's Tech
space where you're reading it and you're
analyzing it but in like six months or a
year or whatever you're going to see a
full video production of I was joking
earlier Professor girvin's six years of
you know uh lectures all condensed into
one hour you know with a AI developed
Professor girvin so it's just one of
those things it's it's going to be
revolutionary but there also needs to be
some safeguards guardrails around it and
I know some countries are doing that I
mean some countries have already Italy I
think was just banned chat gbt but it's
just you know that's where policy needs
to catch up
is one other question here but and then
we'll get wrap up yeah hi Dave Jewell
from Json
bear with me for just a minute so a lot
of the things you came up comes into
mind as an old planner as an educator as
a researcher
and the secretary brought up the morning
about war gaming in the department
usually starts at after insurance has
failed where sauce value is not the same
as we propose it is prior to that
done hundreds of types of War games
in business most of them that we use in
in the work most of them are based on
correlation of forces and means some
sort of attrition model of combat forces
so that
clear data clear logic so we can get to
Mike's opinions based on good research
in the
conflict the contest for influence
in spaces such as your terminal
disinformation so miso or psyops
information support operations are civil
Affairs or expeditionary medicine
is anybody doing this because I don't
know and if so how can we tap into it
using the tools of AI
and machine learning to collect the data
we have
to include at some level the Excursion
into some percentage that is is
misinformation
to apply the Logics with those
parameters that the decision makers set
so you can reduce the ambiguity to a
decision one movement that I'm watching
with Fascination now is a lot of bespoke
bespoke War gaming in wargaming
communities attributed with some of our
pme institutions everything and they're
fascinating but they operate almost
entirely in the opinion world
a war game designer makes rules makes a
good presentation of it
and
thinkers go in and bring their their
experience and their and their wisdom to
it and come out with what they do we
learn lessons from that for military
planning
but how can we use AI to take what is a
combat attrition model in Conflict like
the old movie War Games
and apply it to in the in the space to
the left of battle for influence with
partners and with that and against
adversaries
right now you asked the first thing was
that are we doing this right now the
office of net Assessments in the
Pentagon they are doing this they have
some they have a pilot program that
they're working with ir and DARPA right
now
that it's being developed in such a way
where it's examining all the war gamings
that are hat that have happened with
academic institutions Colombia et cetera
and uh they're compiling all of that
data and seeing how countries have
reacted in the past and how they will
react with the current core technology
capability they may have and what the
Investments are it's still in Pilot
phase right now but I'll get with you
offline and share some additional data
thank you that's in the office of net
assessment that's not over in the j7
world of the more traditional folks yeah
great I'm excited excited and interested
in that I was taking the answer
Christian final thoughts any ideas on
use of AI for simulations war games or
maybe complex decision making that might
uh occur in the future that might help
us think about a strategic challenge
absolutely including the context that
you raised the the you know the the how
do you so conditional on having crisp
definition definitions of what
misinformation is because what's
misinformation to you might be just you
know good information to me
um so as long as we have crisp
definitions of what misinformation is
then I think the the challenging issue
really is that we now have technology in
particular again using these large
language models that currently have been
created and made popular they have two
elements to them the first part is
what's called a Transformer the second
part is what's called a adaptive fine
tuner the Adaptive fine tuner is
designed usually to take bias and
toxicity out of the language model but
that same technique can be used to amp
up the kinds of messages I could send to
a populace
to manipulate them to get Max influence
over them in other words I create
different messages run it by humans and
figure out which messages have the most
capacity to influence somebody so what
we then have is a missionary then that
has economies of scale and scope in
terms of being able to send out over a
network so if you control some kind of a
so if you take Tick Tock or a Facebook
or an Instagram or any of these kinds of
social media platforms you have the
capacity to flood these with messages
and it doesn't have to be just text it
could be to Sam's Point it could be
audio it could be video and I think we
have a very interesting case study
coming up I think I was in a earlier
presentation where there seems to be
multiple elections coming up in multiple
countries including our own
so I think you're going to see a very
significant amping up of the extent of
misinformation and disinformation being
deployed on the internet and I think it
behooves us all I think to do three
things I think one of course is you know
better technology to try and identify
and classify and take out and beat out
this misinformation the question is
who's liable for it you know where where
does the incentive light to remove that
that's one the second I think has to do
with educating people uh to you know as
as as Sam was pointing out don't believe
everything what you see on the internet
that's a long run kind of uh effort uh
and then and then the third is being
able to sort of
um take these types of
um you know this is going to be core to
our democracy so do you think about
content labeling just like we when you
buy wine you know it comes from
California or from Italy should should
content that comes from an AI engine be
actually Watermark should it require
content labeling should there be peer
evaluation you know why in spectator
says that bottle is is a 93 and that
bottle is at 89 so should you have peer
reviews of content so there are lots of
different policy approaches one could
think about as well in addition to this
but it's a hugely complex problem and I
don't think there's an easy solution and
we've been dealing with this now for
it's getting close to a decade and we
don't have really good purely Technical
Solutions because this is a
socio-technical problem it's not a
technical problem alone so any solution
is going to have to be a social
technical solution absolutely
please join me in thanking our panelists
[Applause]
[Music]